قبل 36 عامًا، غض العالم
الطرف عن الإبادة الجماعية التي تحدث في العراق، حيث تم جمع 10
آلاف من المدنيين الأبرياء
ونقلهم بالشاحنات إلى
الصحراء النائية لإبادتهم،
وأصبح هذا الفصل المظلم من تاريخنا الحديث يُعرف بجثث
ضحايا الإبادة الجماعية غير العادية.  ملقاة في
مقابر جماعية لم يتم التنقيب عن بعضها بعد،
خذلهم العالم منذ 36 عامًا،
لم تتحدث وسائل الإعلام عن هذه
الجرائم ضد الإنسانية ولا
الدبلوماسيون، واليوم نشهد
إبادة جماعية أخرى تتكشف في
غزة على عكس الأندال، يمكننا جميعًا رؤية
الصور على شاشات التلفزيون  وعلى وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي، فإن
بعض صلواتي مع
أهل غزة وأحبائهم الذين
يشاهدون بلا حول ولا قوة من
بعيد من العراق، وأطلب أن تكون ذكرى
شهداء الشرج بمثابة تحفيز
للمجتمع الدولي على
العمل.